le plaisir de qui d'abord me
et puis que la bomba par le biais de la
mairie à un concours organisé pour le
les décorations de noël donc on les
inscrit au concours on verra bien si on
gagne le premier commandes et des
lumières wii rouge n'est pas fabriquer
vous même un non non non non aux
électriciens l'électricité mois ses
doigts par les branchements c'est tout
ce que j'ai fait
ça faisait des années que je faisais la
fenêtre et puis comme je voyais beaucoup
de monde ce qui regarde et quand même ça
m'a donné
le faire plus plus grand quoi pour le
plaisir des yeux
bah moi et mon frère on a fait le moulin
puis bal bonhomme de neige aussi qu'ils
sont las derrière nous avons fait aussi
entièrement il ya des personnes qui font
des plus belle encore
on voit l'afflux vision quelques fois
hélas hélas votre nas l'année
non